protest is an American Legacy that each
one of us is supposed to engage in core
value we're supposed to not have an
established God we're supposed to have
freedom of religion core value we're
supposed to have it reverence for the
rule of law a core value that's being
subverted but when you go back to this
bounding generation their vision of what
we're supposed to be is as you say so
much greater than the messaging to us
about you know how we're supposed to
behave like even protest you know we're
supposed to have First Amendment rights
where we can be free to assemble
anywhere in the United States of America
that's what the Constitution says
freedom of assembly no law commercial
pass no law restricting it but for 30
years you know we've seen the space for
protest getting smaller and smaller and
smaller so that like some students but
you know on some campuses are dealing
with protest plazas or rather freedom
plazas free speech plazas like some
little part of the campus where you can
go back and forth and speak and you know
even big marches you know if you ever go
on a march these days you feel like it
was kind of a wasted effort well you're
right your intuition is right because
though nature of the / permit to
cessation of the last 30 years
guarantees that assembly freedom of
assembly in America will be ineffectual
how do I say this I studied the kind of
protest that actually changes outcomes
that brought down the Soviet Union that
restored people power in the Philippines
that liberated the Baltic States and
it's all illegal in America it's protest
in which people stopped traffic you know
in France everywhere Mexico City
people's to Pakistan people stopped
traffic and that protest if it's big
enough always always always works in
America you are not allowed to stop
traffic that's the definition so you
know they move us from hitherto yawn and
we have these permits and we think we've
done something we end up thinking well
that didn't make a change it's designed
to keep us from engaging the kind of
assembly that makes a change in order to
change an outcome you have to be able to
bring business as usual to a halt
so those are examples of how we've been
trained to accept a situation that makes
us ineffectual I mean there are other
examples I have this whole chapter
called fake democracy in which I went on
this journey and tried to use all my you
know rights as the founders intended me
to I tried to get a friend for rent to
run for Senate in Virginia and I
discover that two clicks into the
process the information we need is in
Latin you know it's so legalese so dense
you can't possibly understand it and no
hints as to whom you can hire to help
you understand it and you know just no
translation no no reference to a
translation I try to think about regice
regice turing my neighbors to vote and I
discover am risking a
five-thousand-dollar fine if I make one
bureaucratic error because these
lawsuits against voter registrar's I try
to hold a rally in union square in
support of the Constitution and you know
15 minutes in I'm informed that what I'm
doing is illegal because it's illegal to
use a bullhorn in union square without a
permit right you know meanwhile in all
these retail stores there's sound
blaring out you know into the into the
street you know over and over again I
try to use my rights and powers that the
founders intent me to heaven I find a a
wall put up making it a fake democracy
and I think people into it that that's
there and they don't wanna break their
hearts so they don't plunge into the
process now flipping it around more
hopefully I have found that when people
have that know their rights and have the
tools to make a difference it's so
energizing and so if right now you think
well that's really overwhelming to you
know she tells me how to start my own
political movement I'm really tired and
cranky and over scheduled anyway you
might feel that way now but what does
happen I've seen is that when more and
more people have the knowledge of making
these changes it's very energizing to
the people around them and they see well
my best friend just wrote an op at and
placed it you know the book teaches
people how to do that maybe i can write
an op at in place that are you know g
might my friend just set up this you
know democracy team and they're
confronting
their representative and you know
getting these meetings and having an
outcome may be you know maybe I can set
up my own team it's it's actually very
exciting I mean things that seemed
incredibly boring to me I mean I'm not
even interested in politics you know not
you know i'm not i'm interested in like
poetry and my kids and you know but you
know I'm really not interested in
process you know like initiatives and
referenda you know like who's interested
in that but I discovered that the more
buy-in I had you know and the more roll
I could play the more exciting the whole
idea became and people I'm talking to
her feelings